suchen wir vielleicht an der falschen
stelle nach außerirdischem leben und
zwar erst geht nicht ums weltall sondern
nach der falschen art diese these
vertritt jetzt ein astrobiologe der
technischen universität münchen
demnach gibt es anzeichen dass das erste
leben nicht zellulärer war also aus zell
bestand sondern viren waren sie gelten
heute gar nicht als leben weil sie ohne
einen wird nicht überleben können aber
vielleicht war das ja mal anders und
wenn dem so ist so alexander janjic dann
suchen wir auf dem mars mit den falschen
geräten klicks um science-fiction hier
gibt es täglich spektakuläre science
videos abonniert den kanal nur dann
verpasst er kein video herzlich
willkommen wir hatten ja letztens
überwiesen werden berichtet die etwas ja
fast beängstigendes in sich tragen ihr
genom enthält überraschenderweise auch
die bauanleitung für die protein
biosynthese und das ist bei den tub an
während der fall ein forschungsteam aus
frankreich hatte proben aus einem
alkalischen salzsee in brasilien und
ebenso aus der tiefsee vor der
brasilianischen atlantikküste entnommen
und dabei diese riesen wären aufgespürt
sie hatten am mögen befallen die ihnen
als wird dienten die analyse unter dem
elektronenmikroskop enttarnen sind dann
ihre enorme größe und den längsten
schwanz der jäger ein virus beschrieben
wurde so einer der beteiligten forscher
jonathan sabra hayo das wirklich
außergewöhnlich an diesem virus typ ist
sein genom denn das enthält die
bauanleitung für den gesamten prozess
der protein biosynthese und das ist
wirklich ein novum in der biologie ein
organismus gilt nur dann als lebewesen
wenn er sich selbst vermehren kann
konkret passiert das durch die
sogenannte protein biosynthese bei der
vereinfacht gesagt in zellen neue
weitergebildet werden bisher war klar
dazu sind höhere organismen aber auch
pilze und bakterien in der lage wären
dagegen brauchen wirtszellen um sich zu
vermehren
denn sie selbst besitzen weder die gene
noch die ausstattung um proteine
selbstständig herzustellen und so gelten
wären eben auch nicht als echte
lebewesen bisher
und genau das ist vielleicht der fehler
der unsere sicht verengt und eine zu
enge definition von leben bewirkt aber
genau diese sicht scheint sich jetzt zu
erweitern den forschungsteams haben
schon in den vergangenen jahr
mehrmals neue viren entdeckt die sich
nicht an dieses schema halten dazu
zählen beispielsweise die riesen viren
namens mega virus klos neu viren oder
pandora virus allesamt sind genauso groß
wie bakterien und die erbgut ist
ausgestattet mit viel mehr gehen als man
es bislang von wären kannte konkret
enthält die dna der thuban wären bis zu
1,5 millionen basenpaare und bis zu 1400
25 gene die die proteine kodieren damit
ist es das viertgrößte genom eines virus
das bislang bekannt ist sie enthalten
die bauanleitung für enzyme die alle 20
aminosäuren bauen können und bis zu 70
transporters alles unabdingbare faktoren
für die prozesse der protein biosynthese
und damit ihre eigenständigen vermehrung
und das alles ist auch für die
forschungsteams eine große überraschung
denn all das zusammen gezählt ähneln sie
sehr den echten zellulären organismen
nur eine sache fehlt das sind die
sogenannten ribosomen diese zellulären
gebildet treiben die protein biosynthese
an alexander janjic sagt jetzt wenn wir
das nicht berücksichtigen dann übersehen
wir vielleicht die ersten lebensformen
auf dem mars denn wenn das alles
zutrifft könnten die viren nicht nur
echtes leben sein sondern dann
vielleicht sogar das erste leben auf der
erde
er hat doch die xmas vision ist gar
nicht dafür eingerichteten proben
während zu erkennen zurzeit sei
lediglich geplant so janitsch zelluläre
fossilien bio indizierte sediment
struktur zum beispiel ausscheidungen
oder konservierte organische
verbindungen in zwei metern tiefe
aufgespürt die astrobiologie geht davon
aus dass der mars etwa bis 500 millionen
jahre nach der planetenbildung
lebensfreundlich war in einem für die
evolution relativ kurzen zeitraum könnte
es aber nun sein dass sich eben nur
viren gebildet haben mit dem bisherigen
messmethoden wären sie nicht auffindbar
sein vorschlag deshalb baldmöglichst
vielleicht schon bei der exomars mission
mikroskop ihr geräte mit an bord zu
nehmen die viren im maßstab aufspüren
können
und wenn sie dann die dann finden würden
und zwar nur spuren von wären wären die
konsequenzen revolutionär
dann wäre es tatsächlich so dass viren
die erste entwicklungsstufe des lebens
werden
wow wir halten euch dazu natürlich auf
dem laufenden genau zu diesem thema
außerirdische machen wir
unseren zehn jahre jubiläums 500.000
abonnenten spezial stream am donnerstag
den 13 dezember hier könnt ihr ihn schon
mal vormerken stellt uns gar nicht jetzt
schon eure fragen zu diesem thema die
wir dann im steam beantworten gerne auf
whatsapp der link dazu ist hier ich
freue mich auf viele fragen und
natürlich euch im live stream
bis dann bleib dran